[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK: Hi, and welcome to episode
number 113 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Maddow, and I'm here
with my colleague as always,
Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE: I'm doing great, Mark.
MARK: You're in the
middle of London,
where it's freezing
cold, I believe?
MELANIE: Yeah, I'm
in Europe, where
it's cold and snowy and not
snowy all at the same time.
And you were in San Francisco
where it is unseasonably warm.
MARK: Well, it's San Francisco,
so it is kind of seasonably
warm because it gets warm
in winter for reasons
that I don't understand.
MELANIE: Yeah, you're right.
It does.
But it should be
raining right now.
Anyways, all that
aside, this week,
we're going to talk
to Yifei Feng, who
is a suffer engineer
on TensorFlow,
and so she specifically
works with open source
and the open source
part of TensorFlow
and helping to build tools to
support those who are using it.
So we have a good interview
coming up with her,
but before that,
as always, we like
to get started with
Cool Things of the Week,
and we're going to end
with a question that
is, in essence, if you are
trying to design identity
and access management policies
for GCP, how would you do that?
If you're a large customer
or a small customer,
what would that look like?
MARK: Cool.
All right, well,
why don't we get
stuck into our Cool
Things of the Week?
I'm going to go first.
MELANIE: You're
going to go first?
MARK: Because I feel like it.
MELANIE: Do it.
MARK: I got to go first
because I want to.
So we spoke the other week--
the special episode about the
Meltdown and Spectre security
concerns.
If you're at all familiar,
there is an open source project
called Forseti that we're trying
to get on the podcast as well--
Forseti people, if
you're listening,
please come on board--
that is an open source
product for helping you scan
your cloud systems for security
things and setting up default
policies, things like that.
So there's now actually
part of Forseti
that you can install that
will do scans of your Google
Kubernetes engine
installations to make sure
that they have been updated.
So this will be something that
can scan all of your projects
to make sure whether or
not that's been installed,
so we'll link to
that in the show.
But if you run Kubernetes
engine clusters,
and you want to make
sure you're up to date,
this is a really nice
tool to be able to do it.
MELANIE: All the
things to update.
And I will share that there's
a new announcement in terms
of TensorFlow.
Version 1.5 is now out.
It was actually released as of
January 26, so that is public.
And it's brought to the stage
a couple of different things,
like [INAUDIBLE]
execution, which ultimately
is a functionality that
they've been wanting
to get in place that allows
you to run TensorFlow
operations immediately.
In the past, you'd have to
wrap it and run a function,
but now, you can run it
immediately as if they
were called from Python.
But there's other things
like TensorFlow Lite and GPU
acceleration updates, so go
and update to TensorFlow 1.5.
MARK: Awesome.
And finally, and definitely
not least, if last--
I did that the wrong order.
But we have a new region once
again, which is really cool.
We seem to be popping
these up all the time.
So if you're in Montreal or you
want to host stuff in Montreal,
we now have a Montreal
region supporting
a good chunk of our products.
Per usual, there's
usually a gradual rollout
of different things
to different areas,
but usual band of
thieves I guess--
Compute Engine, App Engine,
Kubernetes, all supported,
cloud storage, et
cetera, et cetera.
You can definitely see that all
in the link in the show notes.
Yeah, if you're running stuff
in Montreal, this is good.
MELANIE: Yeah, it's going to
improve your latency up to 90%
is what they're saying
for the end users
in Montreal, which is
great because we know
there's a lot of researchers.
And we're also seeing a
lot of gamers, so that--
MARK: Lots of game developers.
MELANIE: That's a
real important fact
for those who are out there.
All right, well, I think it's
time to go talk to Yifei.
MARK: Yeah, let's do it.
MELANIE: On today's
podcast, we're
excited to have Yifei Feng,
who is one of our Googlers
who's working on open
source TensorFlow.
Hi, welcome here.
YIFEI: Glad to be here.
MELANIE: Well, before
we get into it,
can you tell us
a little bit more
about what you're working
on, and who you are?
YIFEI: Oh, yeah, for sure.
So I joined about Google
a year and half ago,
and that's also the same time
that I joined TensorFlow team.
I'm a software engineer
on TensorFlow team,
and for TensorFlow, I have
worked on TensorFlow high level
API, so [INAUDIBLE] Estimators,
as well as Tens TensorFlow
Serving, which is a
system that allows users
to deploy their trained
machine learning models
into production.
But I spend most of my time
focusing on building tools
and infrastructures to
help TensorFlow engineers
and TensorFlow users
to do their best work.
So this include setting
up task infrastructure,
continuous
integration, as well as
releasing TensorFlow and
managing the open source
process of TensorFlow.
MELANIE: So you came
on board specifically
to help build out the tools
and to support that open source
community.
YIFEI: It's around the time
when TensorFlow start to really
grow, like half a year after
we open sourced TensorFlow,
and we really do need to devote
some engineering power to make
sure that, with all
these contributions--
so many people have been so
enthusiastic about contributing
to TensorFlow-- we
can still guarantee
the quality and the
productivity of the engineers.
MARK: For those people
who maybe, they're
new to this space or haven't
heard of this before,
can you give us the
30,000 foot view
of what is TensorFlow,
like super high level?
YIFEI: Oh, yeah, for sure.
So TensorFlow is this
open source machine
learning platform, library,
however you want to call it,
from Google.
And so the way it works,
you are representing
your numerical accretion
with these data flow graphs.
So in these data flow
graphs, your mass operations
will be the node, and your data,
or tensor, will be the edges.
So this kind of
flexible architecture
can allow you to
easily run your models
across all kinds of
platforms, so from CPU,
GPU, to embedded system, to
mobile, to server, and even
to customize hardware and such
as tensor processing units.
And it's also really easy
to scale from research
to production.
You don't really need
to change the code much
if you want to, say, deploy
your model into production
right away.
MELANIE: In terms of
working with TensorFlow
and, specifically, the
open source community,
I mean, what's it been like?
What's the community like?
YIFEI: So I'd say the
community is quite inclusive.
It's kind of amazing.
No matter what your background
is, no matter you're
from one of the biggest
company, no matter you're
from a small company,
no matter you're
here, you're in Asia, Europe,
anywhere else in the world,
and no matter you're
just one individual
working on your own thing, you
can, if you have a great idea,
if there's people
who like what you're
going to bring to the table, you
can contribute to TensorFlow.
That's kind of the whole
point of open source software,
just anybody with a great idea,
with ability to contribute,
they can make a contribution.
And we have definitely accept
contributions across board
from small stuff, like, hey,
fix our documentation errors
to huge changes like
support [INAUDIBLE] or Mac,
or support Windows binaries.
So it's kind of amazing
to be able to see
all these kind of
contribution rolling in
and see the whole
community thrive
because of different changes
different people are making.
MELANIE: What are some
of the reasons why
you think Google made the
decision to open source
TensorFlow to begin with.
I know you came on
board after they did.
YIFEI: I feel like AI has been
playing such an important role
in terms of how technology
has been-- like, progress.
And Google being the
lead in this field,
it's great to open up the
core of its machine learning
and let so many people
to be able to collaborate
and also build on top of
that, or see what we are doing
and be like, hey, I
have this new ideas,
and I want to add
on top of that.
So kind of encourage
collaboration
and make sure we're all moving
towards the good direction
together.
MELANIE: I know being
in the AI community,
I've seen a lot of open sourcing
over the last few years,
and it's exciting.
It's a great way to bring
people together to share ideas,
to also speed up the
process and the turnaround
of experimentation and building
up its community as well.
YIFEI: I think it's going to be
really hard for TensorFlow team
to have the time
or the knowledge
to implement a lot of these
things we have right now,
and I guess one of
the reasons TensorFlow
is proven to be so
portable and work across
so many platforms is because
we have so many people.
They work on it, and
they've tried it,
and they made sure
that it worked
across all sorts of platforms.
MARK: So actually, when we
get stuck into sort of--
I know this is part of the stuff
that you've been talking about,
and you mentioned it
came out of Google,
but it's now open source.
Is there like a magic internal
TensorFlow, or how is that?
How is that?
Because I know we do a
lot of research here.
YIFEI: Right, that is a question
a lot of people have asked,
so to a lot of
people's surprise,
it's actually quite similar.
It's pretty much the same.
So I guess if we're going to
talk about the two versions,
it's hard to not talk
about this process we have
to sync the Google
version of the code
and the GitHub
version of the code.
So we accept for
[INAUDIBLE] on GitHub,
as everybody knows,
and meanwhile, we also
accept internal commit
allowing internal repository.
And actually, we
have this rotation.
One TensorFlow engineer,
every week, they
will be on this rotation,
and every day, they
will push all of the internal
changes out to GitHub.
So each internal change
will show up on GitHub
up as a commit, and
at the same time,
they will go review
GitHub pull request.
If it's something
simple, then usually,
we'll just review it, run
the task, and accept it.
And if it's something
more involved,
they usually will assign it
to a TensorFlow core team
member who may have more
context over the topics,
and they will review it.
And eventually, all these
pull requests like on GitHub.
It's not internal yet,
and about once per week,
we'll also do the same thing,
bring all these GitHub changes
back to internal
version of TensorFlow.
So we have this
tool that will take
a long list of the differences
between internal and external
version, and when
I say differences,
it's not really a huge
chunk of differences.
It's mostly things like
mechanical pass changes,
or sometimes we will exclude
some directory if it's not
ready to be released yet.
And sometimes, there is
Google specific dependency
that's just for Google
internal infrastructure, which
wouldn't be useful
outside, and then we
will replace it or remove it for
the open source version of it.
So we run all these transforms
through this tool, which
is actually also open source.
It's called Copybara.
And then we get
open source version,
and we always make sure that,
if we run the tool backward,
we get the same version back.
So it's actually a check that
we ran all the internal changes
to make sure you always can
create an external version,
don't break anything
open source,
and be able to bring back.
So they are actually
pretty close.
I'll say a day or two, a
week, apart from each other.
MARK: So at some point, they--
it's an eventual consistency
model, essentially.
Right?
YIFEI: That's right.
It's actually quite
challenging to managing this.
You can kind of imagine that
having two source of truth
and given the volume that
we're getting from both side,
it's very likely that there are
going to be changes touching
the same piece of code.
MELANIE: I can imagine
that would definitely
be one of the bigger
challenges that you're
dealing with in terms of
dealing with open source
versus the internal.
What are some of the other
challenges you find when you're
working with open source?
YIFEI: I guess that's one
of it, and another thing
we have is just, we're getting
tons of issues on GitHub.
And so we also
have another thing
that's called the
issue rotation, which
is very similar.
So basically, we have somebody
on the team every week that
will go through all the
issues that we're getting,
and they'll do
something similar.
If it's something they
can resolve really fast,
they will try to answer, and
if is something more involved,
especially if it's a performance
issue or clearly a bug,
they will assign it to somebody
who know more about it.
And then somebody
with more expertise
can carry on with
the conversation.
Or if there are
feature requests--
we're getting tons
of feature requests,
so that's also
something that we want
to work on to kind of
apply a label to all
these issues [INAUDIBLE]
contribution will come,
so we can get the community
to join in and help us.
And there are also
people who have
been asking us,
hey, I really want
to contribute to TensorFlow.
What should I do?
And we always
recommend, hey, look
at this list of
Contribution Welcome.
Pick something that
you're interested in.
Send us a support request.
We'll review it.
MARK: So you
mentioned that there
were two sources of truth.
So basically, there's
the outer community
and there's Google, who's also
working on this full time.
How do you determine what
should be worked on with what?
Is there one ruling body, or is
it just kind of free for all,
or what happens?
YIFEI: I think it's more
kind of an organic process.
We don't really have specific
rules of, hey, this feature
needs to be implemented.
These shouldn't be.
[INAUDIBLE] for
any big features,
usually, we will have a plan.
We'll have [INAUDIBLE] review.
We'll have that
implemented internally.
There are also definitely
ideas that we want to do,
but we might not even have
the expertise within Google
to do it.
Somebody else will probably
want it more than we do already,
and they will give us a
contribution on GitHub.
They were more than
happy to accept those.
And then there are
also smaller features
that we might think about
that is good to have,
but we haven't really
got to them yet.
And then if we get
enough momentum
on the community--
from the community,
there's so many people
asking about it.
Then we're like, OK, maybe
we should prioritize that
better because so many people
really want this feature,
and then we work on those.
And some other times, there
are also smaller features.
People just directly contribute
to us, and then we're like,
OK, this totally
makes sense to have.
And we haven't had time to
even do something like this,
and great, we'll
take those features.
MARK: So it sounds
like a really--
YIFEI: So it's more
community driven.
MARK: Yeah, very.
That's what I was going to say.
Sounds like a very strong
community driven process.
That sounds great.
MELANIE: In terms
of TensorFlow, you
were saying before about
how you guys reconcile
between the internal
and external,
and there's a daily
reconciliation to a degree.
It's not necessarily a release.
So what does a release
look like for TensorFlow?
YIFEI: Great question.
So when we talk about this sync
between internal and external
world, this pretty
much all happens
on the master branch of GitHub.
But for release, we usually
cut a release branch,
and everything happens
on that branch.
So usually, we will
have a list of features
that we know we want to
get into the next release,
and then we cut
a release branch.
We wouldn't want any
new unstable change
to get put into
that branch anymore.
So that's the
branch where we will
try to roll out the release
tasks, build our binaries,
and then we will release
an RC version first,
Release Candidates.
Once the release
candidate's out there,
people will try to use
it and let us know,
hey, if there's an issue,
is there a new bug,
and that's one way we
cherry pick new changes
from the master branch
into the release branch
to fix all these
issues that showed up
in the release candidates.
And sometimes, you will need
to go through a few iterations,
and that's when we eventually
announce the official release.
MELANIE: And I know you
have the release 1.5,
and are there specific
features that you
wanted to highlight with
regards to your release 1.5?
YIFEI: 1.5 have all lot
of our exciting features.
Some of them have being in the
preview in the nightly binary
for a while, but there will
finally be an official release.
So for example, TF Lite is one
of the more exciting thing.
It's TensorFlow's
mobile runtime.
MARK: Oh, cool.
YIFEI: Basically, it allows you
to have a really small binary
size and be able to run
your machine learning
model inference on device.
So that's like two
things you care
a lot when you're trying you
do something on meta platforms.
MELANIE: Yeah.
YIFEI: Another thing
that's very exciting-- it's
TF Eager Execution, which I
think was also announced late
last year, just like TF Lite.
Basically, it's the
imperative mode of TensorFlow.
Earlier, we talked about the
standard TensorFlow works
as a data flow
graph versus Eager,
the code will actually
execute the order
you're writing your Python
code, which as you can imagine,
would be great for
debugging or experiment.
MELANIE: Well, this
is great to hear,
and I know that's always
very exciting when
there's a new release.
But also, I know you
get a lot of reaction.
People will experiment and
explore and have opinions,
and I'm sure you see that.
What's it like
managing the reactions
once you do have the release?
YIFEI: I guess for
releases, sometimes
we always need to move forward.
Say, for our GPU
releases, there are going
to be new [INAUDIBLE] version.
We're going to sometimes make
some backward incompatible
changes, so sometimes
this kind of decision
we need to make whether
we want to distribute
our binaries with a
better performance
or like more people
with older platforms
will still be able to use it.
It's quite tricky
sometimes to make
that decision of, hey, do we
want to stay with the older
stuff but sacrifice performance
for a lot of people,
or do we want to
just be like, hey,
we're just going to move
forward because more people will
be able to get out of the
box binaries with better
performance?
But at the end of the
day, there is always
the source code there,
so you can always
build it from scratch.
MELANIE: You can always play
around with it, or explore--
YIFEI: Right, you can
always build your own binary
on the platform that
you want to run.
It's kind of always a
hard decision to make.
MELANIE: When you decide
to stop supporting
certain binaries or
certain backgrounds,
how do you communicate
that out usually?
YIFEI: First of
all, when we decide
to move onto a new
version of something,
we will get some requests from
the community a long time ago.
That's where we
start to think about,
hey, maybe we should do this,
or we know we want to do this,
but that's where we
hear the feedback.
And if more people are willing
to be like, hey, I would rather
update my operating system
or something in order
to get the performance gain,
then we make the decision,
hey, this is
something we should do
because it sounds like
most of the community
would prefer something like this
versus the other way around.
MARK: TensorFlow has obviously
become a very, very popular
project.
Has there been anything you
found particularly surprising
when working with the
open source community?
Was there a feature that
you thought was, like, well,
I never saw that coming?
Or was there any
aspect of that that
you found particularly
surprising or interesting?
YIFEI: A lot of time,
it's very surprising
how many people are
actually working on things,
or how many people have
been paying attention.
For example, before we
had official Windows
binary release, we have been
trying to get it to work.
And when we announced
the intention of, hey,
we're thinking of
releasing a Windows binary,
and I think to our surprise,
Microsoft stepped in
and be like, hey, we have
been trying to do the same,
and here's some
pull requests that's
our progress, which was amazing
because it would have taken us
way longer.
There are probably lots
of this kind of example.
That's one that I remember.
MELANIE: Nice.
Nice.
How large is the community?
YIFEI: It has been growing.
By now, we have about
27k commits on GitHub.
MELANIE: That's very impressive.
MARK: I'm seeing--
YIFEI: 12k contributors.
That's a lot.
MARK: 87,000 stars?
YIFEI: Oh, wow.
And I think we get probably
around 100 issues per week.
Probably around the same
number of pull requests
per week as well,
which is a lot.
MELANIE: I know you were
saying at the beginning
that you find it really exciting
how people build on this, ideas
that they come up with in
terms the way they contribute.
What makes you so
excited, outside of that,
about working on open source?
YIFEI: I think it's a great
learning experience because you
get to see how people
approach the same problem
in different ways.
You see solutions that-- the way
to attack a problem you'd never
even think of.
And you interact with, pretty
much, the experts of fields.
And I guess it's also
about the people.
It's always exciting
to go to a conference
and just run into somebody
that's like, oh, hey,
I remember you from
a pull request,
which is always exciting.
MELANIE: This is cool.
This is cool that you have
so much excitement out
of working with the community.
MARK: So this all
sounds really cool,
and its great to hear your
passion for open source
and the TensorFlow community.
If people are listening in, and
they're saying themselves, man,
I really wish I could get
involved with the TensorFlow
community, what's a
great place to start?
I think you touched on this
a little bit previously,
but I think if we can give
people some concrete examples,
that would be great.
YIFEI: As I mentioned earlier,
one of the greatest place
to start if you want to
contribute code to TensorFlow
is to go TensorFlow's
issue page,
and for everything that
we've liked the community
to contribute, we'll tag with
Contribution Welcome label,
and you can go through those
issues and be like, hey,
this is something
that's very interesting.
Oh, this is really relevant
to what I'm working on,
and I can probably make some
contribution on this field.
And that's one
place that's great,
and another place
is Stack Overflow.
So we have thousands,
thousands [INAUDIBLE]
tagged with TensorFlow
on Stack Overflow,
and it would be
great if somebody
can take a look at
them and be like,
oh, hey, I know the
answer to these questions.
I ran into the same issues.
MELANIE: I think that's
a great example, too,
because there's also
the people out there
who might want to be involved.
They've never done an
open source before,
and they're intimidated by it.
And they don't
think, oh, there's
no way I could solve
these kind of problems
or there's no way I could
contribute to something as big
as TensorFlow.
So Stack Overflow--
YIFEI: It's a great
place to start.
MELANIE: Especially
smaller issues,
tackling smaller issues.
Do you have any recommendations
for best practices
or ways people should think
about engaging, especially
if they've never done it before?
They've done very
little, and they're
very intimidated by this?
YIFEI: I guess it's kind of
similar rules for contributing
to pretty much any
open source projects.
So always do your homework,
understanding the rules for how
to contribute to a project.
So for example, on
TensorFlow's GitHub main page,
there is contributing
documentation, kind of list
out what are the
rules that you should
follow when you contribute.
And then there are
things like when
you are going to
add a new feature,
before you send like
a huge pull request,
it might be good to start an
issue to talk to the maintainer
just to see, hey, if
something that I'm proposing
is going to align with
the general direction
of the project, or even
sometimes, somebody
might already be working on
something similar internally.
And it's always good to
just check up on, hey,
I want to do
something like this.
What do you think?
Do you guys think
it's reasonable?
MELANIE: Is that the
best way, though,
putting an issue in to be able
to get in touch with people?
YIFEI: So if it's something that
hasn't been brought up before,
then there are also a lot of
opportunities on the issue
page, where you can filter
through by the Contribution
Welcome label.
And it's also good to just leave
a message, and be like, hey,
I'm thinking of doing this.
What do you guys say?
And everybody's like, oh,
hey, thumbs up, go ahead.
And then you can
send a pull request
because sometimes there might
be something tricky that you're
not aware of, and maybe
somebody on the team or somebody
proposing the feature
from the community
can give you some
guidance on that.
MELANIE: Do you guys have
any chat channels or anything
that people hang out
in and share ideas?
YIFEI: Not so much.
I think, in terms
of that, usually
we just use GitHub Issues so
people with command on issues.
If somebody likes idea, they
might sum up the comments
or something like that.
MARK: And TensorFlow has
a contributing guideline
that people can go read?
YIFEI: That's right.
So that's on the GitHub page.
MELANIE: Anything
that you wanted
to mention before we wrap this
up, in terms of open source,
TensorFlow, working with
these types of communities?
YIFEI: I guess this
is also something
that's more for a general
contributing to open source.
It's really important, I guess,
to be respectful and mindful
because a lot of
time, people forget,
hey, there's a human
behind the computer,
so everybody contributing
to a project,
coming from such
different backgrounds,
and the way they approach
problem can be very different.
So you kind of always need
to be positive and open
minded to be ready to try to
understand where other people's
opinions are from and try
to explain your opinions,
so if there's any
disagreement, always
kind of be willing to
go in with an open mind.
Try to understand
what's going on.
Try to use all of it.
I think that helps,
when everybody
is in a positive mindset, even
if there are a lot of conflicts
on this pull request,
and people are
going to be working
together trying
to figure things out and
get you the best solution.
So that's something I think--
I find it very important
to encourage more people
to contribute to the community.
MELANIE: I agree.
I think it's great to get a
variety of inputs, especially
across the board in a community.
It's very helpful.
Well, great.
Yifei, I'm so glad you
were able to join us.
Thank you so much.
Anything else you
wanted to plug?
We talked about 1.5 coming out.
Anything else that is coming
out, is being launched--
MARK: Events?
MELANIE: Or events that
are happening, especially
around open source
that you're like, hey,
we need to make sure
people know about that?
YIFEI: I think we do
have a TensorFlow depth
summit coming up.
MELANIE: Yes, you do.
YIFEI: At the end of March.
MELANIE: Yeah.
YIFEI: So [INAUDIBLE],,
I think we're
going to have a lot of
live streaming party.
It'll be great.
MELANIE: Oh, great.
Thank you.
MARK: Awesome.
Well, Yifei, thank you
so much for joining us.
Really, it was great
to have a chat with you
to talk about open
source and TensorFlow.
YIFEI: Glad to be here.
Thanks, guys.
MELANIE: Thanks, Yifei.
We really appreciate you
coming onto the podcast
to share with us
about what you work on
and how TensorFlow
open source is managed.
It was helpful to hear that.
MARK: Yeah, it is
really interesting
to hear about the governance
and the processes that
happen behind large
open source projects.
Those things can seem kind
of unwieldy and chaotic
from the outside.
MELANIE: They are.
MARK: It's good to
see so much strategy
and logic going into it.
MELANIE: I've worked
on open source myself.
It's fascinating and fabulous
and also extremely difficult
all at the same
time, where you've
got this amazing community
that wants to get behind it,
and they have very
strong opinions.
And managing that is
definitely an art.
MARK: Yes.
MELANIE: But it's fun.
MARK: I'm not saying
it's like wrangling cats,
but maybe it's kind of
like wrangling cats.
MELANIE: Maybe it is.
All right, Question
of the Week--
how do I design an identity
and access management
policy for GCP depending on
the type of customer that I am?
And we are getting the
answer from Grace Malison.
She's one of our
solution architects
that has put together
some great best practices.
MARK: Yeah, she's written a
really interesting article
here, as well as a tutorial,
around the differences
and policies that you might
need versus an enterprise
customer versus a startup,
maybe sort of like an education
and training system.
It's really, really nice looking
at a startup, for example.
People often wear many hats.
They have many roles, and
they do a lot of things,
whereas an enterprise, people
can be much more specialized,
and how you might want to set
up your policies depending
on those sort of requirements
you have in your systems.
MELANIE: Yes.
We'll definitely include
the link, as always,
and also I'll mention that
Grace wrote this in conjunction
with Marco Cavalli, who is
a product manager on this.
And so we'll include
that, and we'll make sure
that people have access to it.
Mark, are you going
to be anywhere
new in the near future?
MARK: Still just working really
hard towards Game Developers
Conference here in
March in San Francisco.
MELANIE: That's important.
MARK: How about yourself?
Where are you running off to?
MELANIE: I am going to
go to [INAUDIBLE],, which
is a conference that's talking
about machine learning fairness
from an algorithmic perspective.
It's sharing ideas and various
research that's in the space.
And that's happening
later in February,
but we'll talk about that
again on the next podcast.
MARK: Yeah, can't
wait to hear about it.
Well, Melanie, thank you
so much for joining me
for yet another
week on the podcast.
MELANIE: Thank you.
MARK: And thank you,
everyone, for listening,
and we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]